given that I know that the people vary
in their cognitive abilities
tremendously and that that's actually an
important determinant of their life
outcome it seems to me so let's say
someone tests out at an IQ of around 115
and so you could say look you know
you're pretty damn smart you're you're
up above 85% of the general population
you you could you could probably do a
pretty damn good job as an undergraduate
university if you're also disciplined
right if you were conscientious you hit
the books hard you're gonna you're gonna
come out in the top quartile of your
class assuming that you're doing at a
spectacularly successful spectacularly
selective University but you're gonna
have a much more difficult time as a
master student and PhD level stuff is
gonna be you're gonna be pushing your
luck to to really master that but you
know you could be here's a here's a
domain of what would you call it
industrial organizational activity where
you could really be in the top ten
percentile you know it's like so if you
have an IQ of a hundred and fifteen like
you might make one bang-up plumber and
you can have a spectacularly successful
career as a plumber and maybe as a
manager of other plumbers and all of
that and you know and I mean I actually
happen to be a real aficionado of the
trade so I certainly don't think of that
as something that's a that's a low
quality or low status occupation in the
least but we would we would like to tell
people okay here's here's here's a
here's an intellectual domain that's
probably too high for you to be
successful without working insane hours
to to to to close the gap because you
can do that with insane work up to some
some limited degree but it seems to me
that the logical thing to do at least in
part is to give people a sense of what
their advantages and limitations are and
then say to them okay well given that
here is a place that you could go where
you could be optimally successful and so
you know that's kind of my take from a
policy perspective let's say but like
what have you thought about you know the
massive diversity and intellectual
ability I mean what are the implications
from a policy perspective as far as
you're concerned why
occasional guidance is clearly one I
actually did some consulting and some
research for a nonprofit group called
the Johnson O'Connor Foundation which is
vocational and testing they're not that
big on G but they have the only battery
of tests they bring someone in and do a
full day of cognitive tests and from
that they give some advice about what
kinds of professions match their
cognitive strengths and weaknesses and I
actually did some brain imaging on their
tests and was very interesting stuff you
think because it's hard to do the
psychometrics properly with regards to
vocational guidance because we don't
really know we don't have a good handle
on how to classify jobs into their
various subtypes like John Holland has
done some good work doing that but but
there's so many jobs and it's hard to
figure out what makes two jobs the same
or similar you know no I was at Hopkins
when Holland was there and some of my
friends with graduate students worked
for him and I learned all about that
vocational testing it's very powerful
and as you know it's that's more of his
scales that kind of morphed into more
personality like dementia yeah that's
exactly the Nexus that we want to play
out it's like okay because there is a
reason I know people have been mapping
Holland's Hallman's job categories on to
the big five and with a fair bit of
success you know and we're hoping that
the differentiation don't to the to ten
levels of personality will provide even
more precision but but with more general
policy like okay so find so reasonable
vocational counseling that's a good idea
when does it start to start in junior
high like do you do what the Europeans
do and start to track people into trades
and and and higher education at that
kind of early age the Europeans seem to
have had great success with that
so it's certainly Germans in particular
yeah so it's reasonable to look at but
the problem in the United States there
are so many problems that the way we
conceptualize education
and the whole idea of tracking I don't
know how it is in Canada but in the
United States this idea of tracking has
a very negative balance to it you know
segregating the smart kids into one one
set of classes and the less smart kids
into others and then there's medial
education and there's been a tendency a
strong tendency in the United States to
feel that kids learn from each other so
you don't want homogeneous groups based
on learning ability you want it's so
funny because the people say that with
regards to to let's say academic
achievement but they play exactly the
opposite stunt when it comes to such
things as has childhood sports you know
so it's look at football for example
it's like well hey let's say grenade
like ability it's like you don't have
the people who stumble around on the
field dropping the ball all the time
playing with the top end quarterbacks
and nobody thinks there's a problem with
that they don't say well everyone learns
from everyone else in that situation so
to me it speaks more of a refusal to
admit to the stark reality that there
are massive cognitive differences
between people and to try to actually
start to address that with some degree
of seriousness